bonjour Jean-François isson merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner durant
cette première demi-heure cette sénateur
les républicains de la
Meurthe-et-Moselle rapporteur général du
budget rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne dont on
va évidemment longuement parler dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot du
budget plusieurs actualités ce matin
d'abord dans un entretien à la tribune
Geoffre Bézieux le patron du Medef se
montre assez alarmistice dit nous allons
vers un ralentissement de l'économie
assez net la France ne sera pas en
récession mais certains signaux montrent
qu'on s'en approche vous partagez ses
propos oui d'ailleurs
j'ai lu également que le ministre
l'économie Bruno Le Maire annonce à
ralentissement de la croissance il a
revu à la baisse les chiffres de toute
façon en économie il n'y a pas de
miracle à la fois il y a une
interdépendante de nos économies par les
échanges mondiaux mais vous êtes
d'autant plus en bonne santé que vous
avez vos indicateurs nationaux notamment
au vert ça n'est pas le cas de la France
on a
je dirais un niveau de dépenses
publiques très important un niveau
d'impôts qui est très élevé et on est en
déficit préoccupant du commerce
extérieur et quand dans le même temps
vous avez une remontée des taux
d'intérêt
fatalement on va se retrouver dans un
temps de difficultés économiques
il faut pas le souhaiter donc je voulais
pas
la lecture parce que on le voit la
prévision on a des indicateurs qui
normalement devraient nous mettre à
l'abri mais il suffit parfois de peu de
choses il y a le moral évidemment elle a
confiance à la fois des entreprises mais
aussi du pays et donc il faut arriver
aujourd'hui à remobiliser les français
pour donner un coup de collier
supplémentaire et qu'on sentira des
efforts mais il ne nous a pas échappé
que le climat dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui post retraite n'est pas le
climat le plus favorable vous préparez
le budget 2024 le ministre des Finances
Gabriel Attal le ministre des comptes
publics le prépare aussi Gérard Larcher
ce matin dans un entretien à l'AFP il
dit que la période budgétaire va être
difficile car un risque d'accidentologie
pour l'exécutif et il n'exclut pas une
censure si le budget ce ne s'emploie pas
redresser les finances publiques les
républicains iront jusque là
je ne suis pas à l'Assemblée nationale
mais je crois que mais ça n'empêche pas
bien sûr mais premier élément je pense
que nous avons je le dis des comptes
très dégradés et l'an passé le ministre
de l'Économie a annoncé un budget à
l'Europe
allant améliorer enfin dépensant
davantage et demandant au Parlement de
réduire la voilure 0 pointé sur la copie
il y a eu aucune économie et on est
cette année dans un nouveau duo assez
surprenant le ministre de l'Économie
explique qu'il va falloir serrer la vis
la première ministre demande à chacun de
ces ministres de réduire de 5% d'un
nouveau phénomène de rabot et pendant ce
temps le premier République à chacune de
ces sorties annonce des milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires c'est
incohérent il n'y a pas d'argent facile
il n'y a pas d'argent magique il faut de
l'argent efficace pour redresser la
situation de la France c'est cet
impératif je pense qu'on peut amener les
Français sur cet objectif mais pour ça
il faut de la cohérence il faut de la
convergence et il faut se mettre
réellement au travail mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut qui est dans le budget
il faut d'abord définir des priorités et
effectivement il faut alléger le fardeau
de
pour les classes moyennes d'ici la fin
du quinquennat il faut y renoncer le
chef de l'État il fait beaucoup
d'annonces souvent pas su effet et
peut-être que certaines des baisses
d'impôts qu'il annonce n'interviendront
jamais y compris avant 2027 puisque j'ai
bien compris que la perspective la
fenêtre de tir ce serait dans la
dernière année de son mandat du deuxième
mandat présidentiel je pense que le
sujet est suffisamment sérieux pour ne
pas abuser d'annonces non suivi de
lendemain heureux on va parler de la
commission d'enquête sénatorielle sur le
fond Marianne puisque vous en êtes le
rapporteur hier vous avez auditionné
deux ministres dont la très attendue
Marlène Schiappa à l'origine de la
création de ce fond on va voir les temps
forts de cette audition avec Audrey
vuettaz
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour et Audrey la
commission d'enquête sénatorielle sur le
fond Marianne auditionnait donc hier
l'ancienne ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté Marlène Schiappa une
audition très attendue parce que c'est
elle qui est à l'origine de ce fond
lancée après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut retenir cette
audition et bien après plus de 3 heures
d'audition la ministre semble avoir joué
la carte de l'évitement d'après elle
aurait lancé le fond certes mais elle se
serait ensuite rapidement éloignée pour
laisser son cabinet et l'administration
gérer les appels à projets et la
sélection des lauréats voilà pour sa
position sauf qu'au fil des auditions on
se rend compte que la ministre est
intervenue petit rappel des faits sur
l'un des points parmi les lauréats
fléchés par le comité de sélection on
trouve l'association SOS Racisme dans un
premier temps elle obtient une promesse
de 100.000 euros à ce moment-là le
cabinet de Marlène Schiappa demande à ce
qu'on temporise un peu et que ce soit
acté par la ministre car elle aurait
d'après son directeur de cabinet un
passif avec le président de SOS Racisme
je vous propose pour mieux comprendre
d'écouter un extrait de l'audition du
préfet Jalet son directeur de cabinet
c'était la semaine dernière sous serment
suivi hier de la réponse de Marlène
Schiappa sincèrement elle aussi nous
avons sur cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez ancien donc il y a bien eu sur les
décisions arrêtées en Comity sélection
pour l'un de ces lauréat une affirmation
par la ministre un directeur de cabinet
feta de relations personnelles de
désaccord personnel que j'aurais avec
monsieur le Président des SOS Racisme je
n'ai pas là non plus on me prête
beaucoup de relations personnelles mais
je n'ai pas de relation personnelle ni
de désaccord personnel ancien ou récent
avec monsieur le Président de SOS
Racisme
son directeur de cabinet aurait donc mal
compris d'après elle elle ajoute aussi
que si elle n'a pas octroyé les 100.000
euros à l'association c'est parce
qu'elle a considéré que l'offre de SOS
Racisme ne répondait pas complètement à
l'appel à projet même si le comité de
sélection on avait décidé autrement
précédemment autrement un peu cocasse
que j'ai choisi mais qui résume bien
finalement la tonalité de l'audition
avant d'expliquer pourquoi elle n'avait
pas octroyé la subvention Marylène
Schiappa a concédé ne pas se souvenir de
certains détails à cette période ça a
donné lieu à une réponse un peu ironique
du président Claude Raynal on les écoute
tous les deux
je n'avais aucun souvenir du fait qu'il
y ait eu des discussions sur SOS Racisme
dans le cadre du fond Marianne
aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on me dit
d'après ce que je retrouve dans les
échanges parce qu'on vous dit Madame
c'est ce que vous savez quand même vous
oubliez pas tout de votre vie quand même
ça peut prêter à sourire mais finalement
ça résume bien l'audition la ministre
semble s'être désintéressé de ce sujet
du fond Marianne
monsieur je pense qu'elle s'est
largement défaussé effectivement ces
extraits sont assez révélateurs d'une
stratégie qui m'échappe
je veux peut-être resituer
la naissance du fond Marianne
l'assassinat avec un acte de barbarie
innommable de Samuel Paty le pays et moi
et saisi par les froid une cérémonie en
hommage à laquelle je participais dans
la cour de la Sorbonne
ou il y avait une émotion très forte et
une responsabilité encore plus forte
assez fidèle elle-même elle met en scène
avec un fond mariage allégorie de la
République avec un lancement je dirais
très médiatique et puis finalement quand
on regarde aujourd'hui le déroulement de
la procédure l'organisation
et cette comme envolée
elle ne participe à rien elle regarde de
loin elle ne s'occupe de rien ni avant
surtout elle connaît personne lorsque le
fond Marianne est accéléré pour qu'il en
soit décidé sélectionner en trois
semaines surtout elle reste à distance
je comprenais bien que je j'essaie de
faire la synthèse de ce que nous avons
entendu hier et puis à l'issue pas
davantage et même après il y a plus de
suivi il y a plus de communication et
deux ans après elle essaie de retrouver
dans ses souvenirs dans quelques notes
elle a une activité tellement intense
que tout ça lui a un peu échappé
je pense que la mémoire de Samuel Paty
ne mérite pas d'être sali nous avons un
devoir une exigence de dignité et
d'éthique
hier vous trouvez pendant cette audition
je pense que le comportement qu'il a eu
et lors de l'audition était éloigné de
l'ambition qu'elle disait porter je
pense que c'est évidemment dur c'est
cruel mais c'est ce que je ressens et je
pense que c'est aussi ce qui apparaît
cruellement au-delà des
dysfonctionnements de la légèreté d'une
maille très lâche sur le suivi de je
dirais de la mise en œuvre de ce projet
qui cherchait
à utiliser
intelligemment le réseau associatif pour
combattre les discours séparatistes
comment vous l'avez compris cette ligne
de défense est-ce que vous avez senti
chez elle une volonté d'en dire le moins
possible de donner le moins de prise
possible en vue d'éventuelles pour site
judiciaires puisqu'il enquête est
ouverte
une commission d'enquête donc on se gare
bien on l'a dit j'ai d'ailleurs rappelé
les trois procédures parce que je crois
qu'il faut pas mélanger on est dans un
pouvoir de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement on essaie de s'y tenir et
la stratégie d'évitement permanent de
défauses de ne jamais répondre aux
questions que je pourrais considérer
aujourd'hui comme embarrassante sur des
déroulés d'effets chronologiques qu'elle
n'a jamais contesté qu'elle a refusé de
reconnaître en disant je n'ai pas le
même avis à ce moment-là elle donne son
avis elle explique il y a une erreur ici
il y a une erreur là
ça n'a jamais été le cas elle dit
s'éloigner en même temps à l'arbitre sur
le l'affaire peut-être pas à faire mais
en tout cas sur le sujet SOS Racisme
quel regard vous portez
si vous voulez c'est
confondant de contradiction c'est
finalement c'est dans le droit fil de
son propos introductif lorsqu'elle
utilise les mêmes mots que le rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration manque de transparence
manque d'équité enfin c'est manque et
absence je lui dis donc c'est un aveu et
là imperturbable elle répond pas du tout
mais écoutez enfin les deux mêmes mots
utilisés de la même manière avec le même
sens
chercher l'erreur Audrey était aussi
question pendant cette audition des
fonds octroyal association de Mohammed
cifaoui la première bénéficiaire de ce
Marianne avec 355000 euros oui et tout
part d'un mail dans ce félicite d'abord
la ministre d'après elle autour du 20
avril 2021 elle aurait fait part avec
stupeur de sa stupeur pardon concernant
le montant alloué à l'association de
Mohammed Sifaoui qu'elle a affirmé
pendant votre audition ne connaître
d'aucune manière je vous propose de
l'écouter sur ces deux sujets je n'ai
aucune relation personnelle d'aucune
sorte avec Monsieur cifaoui et je n'en
ai jamais eu je ne suis pas avec
Monsieur cifaoui membre de même
organisations j'ai des membres de mon
cabinet qui reçoivent monsieur Sifaoui à
une reprise lorsqu'il présente un projet
et c'est à cette occasion que mon
cabinet m'adresse un mail c'est le seul
trace écrite que j'ai relative un
rendez-vous entre des membres de mon
cabinet et Monsieur Sifaoui et dans ce
mail il m'explique ce projet c'est à ce
mail d'ailleurs que je réponds puisqu'il
me détaille les montants du projet et je
réponds pardon pour la familiarité mais
c'est un échange qui a évocation à ce
moment-là être personnel je réponds ceci
300ke d'argent de l'État pour ce projet
ça me paraît énorme
sauf que cette ce mail quelle date du 20
avril vous la reprenez à ce moment-là
parce qu'il a été envoyé en réalité le 6
avril quelques jours avant même le dépôt
de dossier de l'association et le comité
de décision qui interviendra le 13 avril
on se rend compte que des arbitrages ont
commencé avant même l'envoi et l'analyse
des dossiers alors Monsieur Husson
est-ce que comme l'inspection générale
de l'administration vous trouvez que les
conditions d'attribution du fond
Marianne n'ont été ni transparentes ni
équitable
que vous donnez effectivement c'est un
mail du 6 avril le 13 avril c'est pas un
comité de décision c'est un comité de
programmation mais c'est pas grave et
l'histoire finit de toute façon à 355
000 donc ce qui est énorme ici
sous-entendu
circuler il n'y a rien à voir il faut
faire autrement fini à
355100 sourciers des yeux enfin c'est
juste de la contradiction permanente
et c'est pour moi grave parce que ça
donne ou sa conforte c'est les ceux qui
ne croient plus à certaines valeurs de
la République on est sur un engagement
je le rappelle un engagement fort une
ambition de combat contre le séparatisme
de travailler avec le monde associatif
sur un sujet délicat
sur laquelle sur lequel pardon pour la
première fois moi je touche les choses
de près donc on comprend la difficulté
de mener ce combat et tout ça est balayé
d'un verre de main par des légèreté par
même des
je dirais une app à ce stade une absence
de vérité on ne reconnaît aucune erreur
pas de faute ou TF1 c'est c'est pour moi
c'est inconcevable on a un espèce de
déni puisque je l'ai dit c'est chaque
fois c'est du contournement de la
défausse c'est pas moi c'est le comité
de sélection bah dans le comité de
sélection il y a juste trois membres de
son cabinet avec mon cabinet c'est mon
cabinet c'est juste c'est pitoyable
parmi les manquements que vous avez
relevé aussi c'est le manque de suivi
finalement à la fin on a qu'une feuille
excel avec le nom des associations
retenues les montants qui leur sont
alloués pas de bilan pour une demande de
subvention il y a pas de bilan ça n'est
même pas renseignant en termes de
méthodes pour quelles raisons n'attribue
telle ou tel montant et puis après
normalement il y avait un suivi qui
était prévu tout ça est fait de manière
je l'ai dit très lâche très léger il y a
tellement que vous là parce que vous
avez commencé vos travaux il y a quand
même quelques semaines vous ne savez pas
vous n'arrivez pas à voir à quoi on
servir les fonds on produit les
associations bénéficiaires
on a des éléments de bilan il y en a qui
ont très bien travaillé on a fait des
auditions il y a des productions je
dirais de qualité où on comprend on
mesure le travail qui est fait la
difficulté et ça on aurait pu le
comprendre c'est le cas de l'association
de Mohammed cifaoui par exemple ah non
là c'est non là vous avez bien vu lors
de l'audition il y a là il y a
énormément enfin c'est même plus de la
légèreté il y a quasiment une absence de
production enfin une fois par semaine
des contenus très légers c'est pour ça
que c'est préoccupant parce que ça met
en difficulté le gouvernement et la
ministre par rap je le redis par rapport
à l'annonce on est normalement dans une
stratégie de combat ce qui est
institutionnel et puis là le avec le
réseau astuces pour essayer de pénétrer
et de combattre les jeunes notamment
par la voix des réseaux sociaux et donc
annoncer pour ne pas faire c'est à la
fois salir la mémoire mais ce n'est pas
être à la hauteur de la responsabilité
ministérielle et des équipes qui doivent
au contraire montrer l'exemple pour
donner le meilleur d'elle-même en
s'appuyant sur les associations c'est un
pari et je pense que le pari il est
chargé aujourd'hui d'amertume c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire pour celles et
ceux qui ont pu croire ou croire encore
à la nécessité de ce combat le présent
Claude rénal dit que c'est un fiasco
c'est votre avis aussi oui je pense
qu'on utilisera différents mots
certainement dont celui-ci mais moi je
est-ce que vous seriez jusqu'à parler
d'un scandale d'État
le côté c'est difficile à dire moi je
place d'abord enfin excusez moi mais au
dessus de tout ça je place le combat
pour les valeurs et qui a été salie la
promesse n'est pas tenue et ça a un côté
je veux pas être voilà j'utiliserai pas
le mot que j'ai à la bouche parce que il
est il est vulgaire et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment rester à la hauteur de la
promesse qu'on a faite et je pense qu'il
faut s'employer à la tenir et remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier c'est à dire se
remettre au combat parce que une des
conclusions que je tire à titre
personnel à cet instant c'est qu'on n'a
pas réussi en fait il y a que quelques
associations c'est un combat qu'il faut
mener sur le territoire national mais
certainement également au-delà sur les
réseaux oui bien sûr sur le avec les
réseaux sociaux donc il va falloir
changer de modèle
être beaucoup plus ambitieux mettre des
moyens parce qu'il faut il faut envoyer
un signal à ceux qui nous veulent du mal
à ceux qui veulent mettre à bas notre
république de manière pernicieuse et on
peut pas laisser faire des choses comme
ça sur les territoires nationales
c'est une question de fierté et aussi de
souveraineté vous avez entendu Marlène
Chapa pendant un peu plus de trois
heures hier est-ce que au vu de cette
audition elle peut rester en poste
aujourd'hui c'est une décision qui
appartient auprès d'un public à la
première ministre chacun dans son rôle
mais vous qu'est-ce que vous en dites
je veux comment dirais-je je pense que
Marlène Schiappa on a l'impression dans
vos propos que vous trouvez qu'elle a
quelque part abîmé la République est-ce
que du coup elle peut rester en poste la
question je vais vous dire la question
c'est aussi une certaine une question
personnelle pour elle et de dignité y
compris de la responsabilité qu'elle a
accepté je pense que c'est elle de bien
regarder
face à sa conscience et d'en tirer
certains enseignements vous additionnez
Mohamed cifaoui ce matin est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres auditions de prévues
on est plutôt dans la voilà dans la
phase finale
on a trois mois maximum et de toute
façon on avait comme objectif que pour
au plus tard à la mi-juillet nous
rendions notre rapport définitif
on suivra évidemment vos travaux
Jean-François Husson on va continuer
avec vous on va remercier Audrey à tout
à l'heure à tout à l'heure on va parler
d'un tout autre sujet les Jeux
Olympiques 2024
on va parler actualités dans votre
département pour terminer Jean-François
isson on va à Nancy on retrouve Michael
de Meaux bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Michael directeur
départemental de la Meurthe-et-Moselle
pour l'Est Républicain on va parler d'un
tout autre sujet c'est cette inquiétude
après l'incendie qui a touché le
département des Vosges et qui a ravagé
30 hectares est-ce que la Meurthe et
Moselle est aussi menacée oui bonjour la
Meurthe-et-Moselle
est en alerte orange depuis le début de
la semaine alors ma question monsieur
sénateur elle est simple est-ce que nous
sommes prêts à affronter cet été qui
s'annonce déjà dangereux et est-ce que
les pompiers ont les moyens d'affronter
les semaines qui viennent
alors je pense d'abord bonjour Michael
demo
la Lorraine et le nord de la Loire
d'ailleurs est inverse enfin connaît une
météo plutôt inversée puisque nous
sommes dans des phases de fortes
chaleurs
alors qu'on est même pas au début de
l'été ce qui est assez inhabituel et
pour répondre à vos questions oui je
pense que en tous les cas les équipes
des pompiers dans les départements
mettent en œuvre beaucoup de moyens se
préparent puisque ça ne vous a pas
échappé les sapeurs-pompiers dans les
centres départementaux d'incendiés de
secours se prépare au combat de
sécheresse et d'incendie d'été
ils apportent d'ailleurs souvent jusqu'à
maintenant les équipes qui sont au nord
de la Loire viennent en renfort là où il
y a des incendies et jusqu'à maintenant
c'est plutôt au sud de la Loire des
formations spécifiques sont conduites
des moyens supplémentaires sont déployés
parce que nous sentons bien venir des
besoins à nouveau et malheureusement
l'incendie de forêt qui vient de se
produire dans les Vosges on est
l'illustration
à lire également Michael aujourd'hui
dans l'Est Républicain c'est d'ailleurs
votre une et un dossier sur le
renouvellement des papiers d'identité
qui devient un véritable cassette
particulièrement pour les petites
communes
du moment dans les territoires selon le
maire de Blamont que vous connaissez
monsieur sénateur il y a 10 millions de
titres à produire en ce moment mais
seulement 2750 mairies équipées
actuellement en France est-ce qu'il va
falloir revoir un peu l'organisation
parce que vraiment ça coince en ce
moment alors si je vais vous dire ça me
met en colère j'ai interpellé par une
question écrite en avril 2022 Bruno Le
Maire je n'ai plus de réponse j'ai
obtenu à la fin de la discussion
budgétaire de décembre dernier des
moyens supplémentaires donnent accorder
aux collectivités pour pouvoir répondre
mieux encore un service je le dis qui
relève de la responsabilité de l'État et
qui a été transférée aux communes sans
mettre les moyens correspondants et je
vais même vous dire plus loin
aujourd'hui la première ministre annonce
un va annoncer un certain nombre de
dispositifs de France ruralité ben
écoutez c'est pas Radio Nostalgie que
j'écoute mais je vais vous donner
quelques éléments premièrement il fut un
temps pas si lointain ou quand vous
habitiez la plus petite commune de trois
habitants de mon département vous alliez
en mairie vous donniez vos papiers un
mois après vous aviez vos papiers
d'identité aujourd'hui on a numérisé au
début de la numérisation ce que j'ai
refait le point avec l'initiateur du
dispositif il y a peu de temps en moins
d'une semaine vous aviez votre nouveau
titre numérisé donc on a perdu sur toute
la ligne on a dégradé la qualité de
service en réduisant la proximité en
mettant des contraintes et en
désorganisant les services publics les
tout le monde est mécontent les
demandeurs le coût pour les Mairies
l'État qui n'est pas à la hauteur on a
une chaîne d'organisation qui finalement
est un empilement c'est un espèce de
labyrinthe qui ralentit l'efficacité le
prix du service il faut simplifier il
faut retrouver une ligne directe le pari
qu'on devrait faire c'est de revenir au
début et de dire je le document est prêt
huit jours après je l'ai à la maison en
tous les cas je vais le rechercher à la
mairie c'est ça qu'on doit rechercher et
dans les territoires ruraux aujourd'hui
ça participe avec la dégradation d'un
certain nombre de services avec la des
qualités de route qui ne sont plus les
mêmes avec des services qui ne sont pas
plus toujours aussi accessibles à un
sentiment de déclassement et moi qui
suis originaire d'un village de 50
habitants je n'oublie pas cette
responsabilité qui est d'offrir une
qualité de service la meilleure possible
à tous les habitants de tous les
territoires de notre beau pays de France
Merci Michael d'avoir été avec nous et
c'est la Une de La républicain on disait
papiers d'identité patience et il en
faut effectivement merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin Mickaël
et merci Jean-François Husson d'avoir
été notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure dans un milieu dans le club
des territoires on parlera des Jeux
Olympiques 2024 la France est-elle prête
alors que les inquiétudes sont là sur le
coude l'événement et sur la sécurité
pour les athlètes et les spectateurs on
va en débattre dans 20 minutes d'abord
on a que notre chaîne invité c'est Bruno
retailleux
[Musique]